υπήρχαν στιγμές που παύλως είπε δεν αντέχο θα τα παρατήσουδύσκολες σίγορα επίρχαν κάποια παράπονο ο
πάθος υπήρξαν κάποιες επιστολές προς τον πρόεδρο της κυπριακής εις τοπλογής ομως πονδίαςεπιλήθηκε αυτό το
πρόβλημα σήκωσαν τχαράκι του τα πέτνων και έκαναν τις εγώ πρινν που λιπακοστου οντίνου ίχαμέσα
στο μιαλόμο ότιάν δεν άλλαζαισοροποίες τηδηαδίαα όμα ικο γιανα μου θα επρεπε να επεντίτα περισότενα
λευτά για να κάνειο βαύλωση στοπλοα εγώμεσα στον μια λο μου ήταν ότι θα σταματούσα
κόμένος τόχος είπαμε λημπιάδα του λος αγελές στο ποσιοκτώ στόχος σίγουρα δομόδε στου πριοτιτονιρομο είναιι
έναξαναγό στο αθρο πάύλο κεφταίτι την επόμενη μέρα μετά τους ολμπια ακοτοκτώ σκέφτε έχει πολλά
πράγματα που μααρέση να κάνων ένα βαυτά είναι εμτιβέσι να πί επίσης υπάρχουν σκέψει γιαακατημιά
ι κιοπλοίάς ιγωνείς ταεσύμαχισστα παιδιά τους δεν πρέπει να ζούνε τιςδικές τους επιθήσεις και τα
δικά τους θέλο μέσα αό τι δωή το παθιών τους απλά να ταβοηθάνε να λοοιλήσουν
καια να καταφέρουν αυτά που τα ίδια θέλουν και δι και αυτά ο αγαπομίδκηλεςκαι φίλι
άλλο ένα αντενα λά τα σήμερα μαζί σας ιδιαίτερη τιμή αφού μαζί μας είναι ένα
ολιμπιονίκης που μας χάρισε αρκετές συγκινήσεις στην τελευταίολημπιάδα και όχι μόνο ο πάύλος κοντίδης πύλος
ευχαριστώ πολύ που αποδέχθηκες να είσαι σήμερα στο πόταστνα ο ευχαριστεκά την πρόσκιση γικαρι πέρασε
όλους τους τηλεαδες αρχικα να πούμεστον κόσμο που δεν νομίζω να αχι κάποιο που δέξε
ποιο είναι ο πάύλος κοντύδης θαλσκοντήτης γενήθ και ένται καλευτέρι νια κόσ ενενήταν στηλεμεσών εξιχρόνώ
προσπάθησαν απάνα ξεκίνησε ι διοπλογία βασικάνμε πήρα ν οιγωνίς με δεν προσπαθι αργό στον αυτικών
ελεμεσού πάν ότι είμε μου πολύ μικρός ξεκίνηθα όταν μουνα νέα